The biggest task in learning a language
is acquiring words. You need a lot of
words. At first you need some of the key
words so that you can say something, and
so that you can understand simple
content in the language. But in the long
run, you're going to have to learn a lot
of words. LingQ makes that easy. Trying to
learn words from a list doesn't work.
LingQ helps you learn words from a
context, from a meaningful context, so
just simply follow the instructions,
convert the blue words to yellow words,
save them. Don't worry about whether you
can remember them, you're gonna forget
them, I always forget them, and you'll
meet them again as yellow words, but just
simply work your way through the content
creating as many LingQs as you can, saving
words so that the known words total and
your LingQs total increases, and that's an
indication that you are on your way to
learning the language.